[Music]
Ukraine says at least three people have
been killed in a Russian missile strike
on the port city of Odessa it is the
second straight day of attacks on
Ukrainian cities the regional
Administration says that four missiles
were fired from a ship in the Black Sea
the three victims were working at a
warehouse this attack coming a day after
Russian airstrikes on the city of
kriviri killed 11 people well we'll be
in Russia in just a moment with Yulia
shop of Oliver who's in Moscow first
though let's go to Jonah Hill in the
Ukrainian Capital Kiev Jonah what more
can you tell us
well as you say 24 hours ago a
five-story building apartment building
hitting crevy Rick that Central City via
cruise missiles strike the death toll
there incidentally in the last hour or
two has gone up to 12 with 30 injured
and and then in the early hours of
Wednesday morning it was the Black Sea
port city of Odessa that was struck in
what some of course will see as Russia's
response to Ukraine's ongoing
counter-offensive uh making small
advances in the east and south of the
country of the four caliber missiles
we're told that were fired from the
Black Sea at Odessa 3 were down by air
defenses one got through hitting as you
said civilian infrastructure there a
warehouse also a residential complex and
a shopping mall among the sites damaged
by that missile early reports came from
emergency workers worried about further
victims under the rubble but the death
tolls you said still stands at three
with some 13 injured and also on
Wednesday morning attacks are on Eastern
cities in the Donetsk region kramatosk
and constantinifica houses destroyed
their victims reported three dead and
three more injured that's an area not
far from where Ukraine is reporting
making slow but steady advances in the
vicinity of the city of Batman
Jonah another ongoing point of concern
is the nuclear power plant in Zappa
region now the uh Mr Grossi the head of
the international atomic energy agency
was expected to head there what can you
tell us about that what are you
expecting
well the Asian country he's been here
since Tuesday when he met President
Vladimir zielinski Rafael
to visit this operation nuclear plant on
Wednesday we understand that trip has
been postponed possibly only for a
matter of hours because of travel safety
concerns the plant is of course situated
in zapparesia region in territory
controlled by Russia since the early
stages of the war it's very close to the
front lines and so there will be
concerns about getting there it's not
the first time though that there have
been concerns about its Safety and
Security because of fighting that has
often taken place nearby but the most
recent event that exacerbates those
concerns is the breaching of the kakovka
dam last week it's
it's a cool it's six reactors worries
about water supply but also about the
Integrity of that cooling Reservoir lead
Mr Grossi to want to go and see the
dangers he said for himself he has a
permanent team based there and he told a
press conference on Tuesday uh that the
latest situation was a step in the wrong
direction essentially appealing away of
another layer of safety and proportion
time uh Jonah Hall live in Moscow there
thank you very much Jonah now Belarusian
President Alexander lukashenko says that
his country has started taking delivery
of Russian tactical nuclear weapons
we're joined by moscow-based journalist
Julia shop of Oliver Julia why does
Russia want Belarus to have these
weapons so badly because Vladimir Putin
personally has been spearheading this
well that's right but first I would like
to mention that the battles between the
two armies are raging on in and around
five regions pro war bloggers report
about the fighting in the zaparosia
ugleta Donetsk lugansken directions
regarding zaparosia the front line in
that direction has not significantly
changed the withdrawal of heavy
equipment and the concentration of
Manpower particularly in Makarov get
suggested that the enemy Was preparing
to attack again there basically all the
information we receive is about
Ukrainian attacks and Russia's
counter-attacks that are going on
Non-Stop the bloggers report about
severe fighting but say that Russia
keeps repelling the attacks using
artillery and Aviation and uh talking
about lukashenko we just heard from
um from Belarusian president saying that
Belarus would enter the conflict in
Ukraine if there was aggression against
the country so basically the tactical
nuclear weapons which was promised to
Belarus is going to serve as a means of
deterrence but obviously it's a very
dangerous case and everyone understands
that but at the moment we see that uh
the equipment and tactical nuclear
weapons has already been deployed into
Belarus and the preparations have
already started and a lot of equipment
have been
basically changed and modernized to use
that tactical weapons uh meanwhile on
Tuesday June the 13th a Putin commented
on the situation in the Russian border
region of belga road which constantly
comes Under Fire from the Ukrainian side
and he stated that Ukraine wants to
divert Russian forces and then send them
to
um to border to the Border region from
other directions critical for Kiev and
therefore it was necessary to strengthen
the Border according to Putin and he
also claimed that the buffer zone would
be created to prevent the shelling of
the Russian territory so the situation
is kind of heating up that right